بالحديث عن دروس التاريخ هناك درس اخر لكن
روسيا تعلمت افراغوا المدن الاوكرانيه من
السكان والوسيله قطعوا الكهرباء المدن
الاوكرانيه ليست دافئه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
الموحله ستتجمد قريبا وعوده الهجوم الروسي
امر حتمي هذه رؤيه
اوكرانيا تحولت الى
ثقب اسود هكذا وصفت بروكسل المشهد القذف
الروسي افقد البلاد ثلث انتاجها من
الكهرباء
تغير المعطيات تتغير المعادله فلاح حاجه
للسلاح والاموال بقدر معدات الطاقه مطالب
اوكرانيه جديده والاستجابه الغربيه حاضره
وفوريه مليار و100 مليون دولار من واشنطن
لكن هنا تظهر معضله اخرى ضرب المحاولات
عاليه الجهد اكثر من محطه انتاج الطاقه
والهدف تحويل شبكه الاوكرانيه الى شبكات
صغيره منفصله النتائج تعقد مهمه نقل
الكهرباء من اوروبا وهذا اتهام امريكي
معضله ثانيه روسيا حتى الان استهدفت
محولات بقدره 3030 كيلو فولت لم تستهدف
المحولات الاكبر والسبب هو انها تنتج فقط
في روسيا لا محولات غربيه بنفس الخصائص
وبالتالي لابد من اصلاحها
كوابيسو حكومه
محطه التدفئه وقتها المياه تتجمد داخل
الانابيب والرهان هنا شده بروده الشتاء
درجه الحراره سالب 10 تمدد الجليد داخل
الانابيب وبالتالي تدمير شبكه توزيع
العلميه وفي المعضلات الثانيه كان الاصلاح
صعبا اما هنا الاصلاح لن يتم الا بحلول
الربيع